CHUCK BARON, GOOD TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR >> THANKS
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEFR
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEFE
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEFT
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEFA
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEF,
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEFI
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEFE
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEFD
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEFI
>> Tucker: HE IS THE CENTER BEFN
BALTIMORE.
HE KNOWS A LOT ABOUT THE CITY.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM JOIN
US.
HERE'S GREG CARSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
SO, YOU'VE SPENT A GOOD CHUNK OF
YOUR LIFE IN BALTIMORE.
IT'S A SAD CITY.
I THINK IT'S A CITY WITH A LOT
OF PROMISE.
>> AS A PEDIATRIC NEUROSURGEON,
I SPENT MANY HOURS, SOMETIMES
OPERATING ALL NIGHT LONG TRYING
TO GET CHILDREN OF BALTIMORE AND
OTHER PLACES AROUND THE WORLD A
SECOND CHANCE.
USUALLY WE WERE SUCCESSFUL, BUT
A FEW DAYS LATER I WAS IN A
HORRIBLE DILEMMA, BECAUSE SOME
OF THOSE KIDS HAD TO GO BACK TO
BALTIMORE WHERE THEY WERE AND
TESTED WITH RATS AND ROACHES
AND MOLD AND VIOLENCE.
SOMETIMES I WOULD EVEN CONSIDER
EXTRA TEST SO THEY COULD STAY IN
THE HOSPITAL.
NOW, FORTUNATELY GOD'S GIVEN ME
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS I'M
DELIGHTED TO BE A PART OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
WHILE I WAS THERE, I WORKED ON A
LOT OF ISSUES WITH MANY
POLITICS, POLITICIANS, INCLUDING
ELIJAH CUMMINGS.
I DON'T THINK HE'S A BAD PERSON
I THINK HE IS ACTUALLY WORKING
HARD TO TRY TO HELP PEOPLE.
I CERTAINLY DON'T THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A BAD PERSON.
HE'S WORKING VERY --
I ASKED HIM WHAT WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO WORK WITH ELISHA
CUMMINGS TO BRING SOME RELIEF TO
THE PEOPLE?
IN THE MEANTIME, HE'S GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH THE PROGRAMS.
INVESTED INTO THE AREAS THAT ARE
DISTRESSED.
GOVERNOR HOGAN IS DOING A
GOOD JOB.
ALSO, UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT A VERY
LOW LEVEL.
MANUFACTURING HAS COME BACK,
WHAT WAGES ARE GOING UP.
PRISON REFORM.
ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING.
THESE ARE NOT THINGS THAT A
PERSON WHO IS A RACIST WOULD DO.
WE ALLOW OURSELVES TO BE
DISTRACTED BY THE SINKS.
I THINK WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
TRYING TO SAY IS THAT RATHER
THAN SPENDING YOUR TIME TALKING
ABOUT OUR GREAT BORDER AGENTS
AND INVESTIGATING ENDLESSLY INTO
THINGS THAT YOU CAN'T FIND
ANYTHING ON, WHY NOT SPEND SOME
TIME WORKING MORE TO THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING AND
THAT HE IS WILLING TO WORK WITH
THEM?
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE
ASKING FOR.
>> Tucker: I WONDER IF A CITY
IN WHICH 65% OF ALL KIDS ARE
GROWING UP IN A SINGLE-PARENT
HOUSEHOLD, I WONDER IF YOU CAN
GET ANYWHERE WITHOUT ADDRESSING
THAT.
>> YOU NEED TO ADDRESS THAT.
YOU NEED TO ADDRESS THE FAMILY
ISSUES.
THERE WAS A POVERTY STUDY, AND
IT CONCLUDED AFTER A MASSIVE
STUDY THAT THERE WERE THREE
THINGS A PERSON COULD DO TO
REDUCE THE LIKELIHOOD OF
POVERTY.
NUMBER ONE, FINISH HIGH SCHOOL,
NUMBER TWO, GET MARRIED.
NUMBER THREE, WAIT UNTIL YOU'RE
MARRIED TO HAVE CHILDREN.
HAVE MOVED US IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
WE SHOULD ACTUALLY UTILIZE THE
DATA.
SEE WHEN I'M SO GLAD TO HEAR YOU